[Música]
miles de personas continúan en las
calles en protesta contra las reformas
judiciales que están en curso en Israel
el Primer Ministro Benjamín neta Yahoo
respaldado por su coalición
ultraderechista Ha logrado promover
enmiendas para limitar la acción del
poder judicial frente al gobierno y la
última medida aprobada hace muy difícil
la destitución de un Primer Ministro
vamos al análisis con Brian Acuña quien
es licenciado en relaciones
internacionales el profesor
universitario y estudiante de la
maestría de diplomacia de la Universidad
Nacional de Costa Rica especializado en
el tema de oriente medio Muchas gracias
Bryan por acompañarnos
Hola un gusto y más bien muchas gracias
a ustedes por la invitación el último
texto que fue aprobado en Israel
estipula que un Primer Ministro solo
puede ser considerado no apto por
motivos de salud o mentales y que solo
él o su gobierno pueden tomar esa
decisión la ley llega tras los llamados
de los opositores para que el fiscal
general declare netanyahu no apto
precisamente porque tiene problemas
legales y netanyahu se está blindando de
frente está poniendo en peligro digamos
el buen funcionamiento de la democracia
hasta este momento se acusa anetaneado
de estar intentando socavar la división
de poderes de hecho que la reforma
judicial que tiene tres aspectos o tres
Pilares fundamentales está generando
bastantes polémicas porque por un lado
trata de anular de alguna forma la
manera en la cual la corte puede de
alguna en alguna vía digamos evitar la
invalidación de algunas normas también
la elección de algunos jueces que
también estarían tratando de ser
impugnados o tratando de ser motivados a
través del ejecutivo y por otro lado
incluso el tema como bien mencionas de
la inhabilitación de ministros verdad
los cuales solamente por asuntos de
salud o asuntos mentales quieren
involucrarlos Dentro de este tema en el
caso de netaniao y de otro ministro que
en algún momento renunciado como fue el
caso de Abismo abimaos quien renunció
semanas atrás
despierta digamos esta polémica porque
en el caso de abimaos
hubo digamos una situación ahí de de
juicio en contra de él y en el caso de
netaniao si bien hay unas causas
abiertas por el otro lado no existen
dentro de estas causas algunas en las
que vayan a ser en las que él vaya a ser
judicializado de hecho se desestima de
que vaya a poder ser condenado por estas
causas pero aún así se ha querido
blindar para evitar de que la corte
pueda tener injerencia en este tipo de
aspectos Claro pero por eso le quiero
preguntar o le preguntaba hace un
momento si esto para usted es un
problema para la democracia en Israel
porque claro para los opositores Pues el
gobierno está aprovechándose y está
minando el poder de la ente judicial sin
embargo pues hay que entender cómo
entienden los ultranacionalistas y los
Ultra religiosos judíos la a la corte
Suprema que lo perciben como un tribunal
de izquierdas y que al final para el
gobierno interviene en exceso en las
tareas legislativas Entonces al final
aquí hay equilibrio o lo que hay es un
abuso del abuso de los poderes
el problema principal Perdón en cuanto
al al tema del gobierno es querer
cambiar un poco las normas en la
aprobación de leyes Israel es un país
que no tiene una constitución como
ocurre con otros países también que no
la tienen Pero ellos en su estructura
tienen leyes fundamentales básicas que
tienen una función
constitucional acá el problema está en
que se quiere cambiar un poco el
blindaje y darle todavía mucho más
fuerza a las coaliciones existentes en
estos momentos la coalición que tiene
letanía o que lo ha llevado el poder que
está compuesto incluso por partidos
ultraconservadores verdad con con
figuras polémicas como los son benet
Beer y smotrich
lo que está buscando de alguna manera es
que una coalición Tan pequeña con 64
escaños de 120 que tiene el parlamento
puedan hacer cambios fundamentales
Entonces es la mayor crítica que existe
Y de alguna manera
una parte digamos de la población
israelí sostiene de que sí esto socava
la la democracia Por otra parte
hay algunos que creen necesaria la
reforma pero no esta reforma propiamente
De hecho por eso también el presidente
de Israel Verdad que es una figura un
poco más de carácter diplomático no
tiene decisión en El Ejecutivo pero el
presidente de Israel y zaguerson había
hecho una propuesta también que se
denominó directrices de los pueblos
donde se trataba de hacer una serie de
reformas o contrarreformas a lo
propuesto por yarif levín que es el
ministro de Justicia que trajo la
reforma sobre la mesa y que ha sido
impulsada por netaniao con la intención
de tratar de mantener siempre fuerte y
la división de poderes de una manera
establecida y de una manera digamos este
un poco más más
centrada verdad aún así el gobierno se
ha sentado sobre su posición y rechazó
la propuesta de ederson y siguen
manteniendo este carácter o esta esta
idea de de imponer la reforma que ellos
están promulgando
mire ayer se conocieron avances de una
posible alocución de un posible
pronunciamiento del jefe de la cartera
de defensa pidiendo que frenaran las
reformas Pues en medio de todos los
desórdenes que hay en las calles y que
parece que no tocan piso
paralelo a esto la fiscal general ya le
había prohibido a netanyahu que se que
se que se inmiscuyera dentro de las
reformas y le pidió que se mantuviera al
margen lo que le quiero preguntar es si
está estos rumores sobre el jefe de la
cartera de defensa podrían tener que ver
con un descontento en las fuerzas
armadas y pues Qué consecuencia podría
traer esto para el gobierno
sí la las fuerzas armadas y una parte de
esto se han rechazado incluso hacer
ejercicios o mantenerse dentro de la
parte activa incluso reservistas verdad
han rechazado la posibilidad de mantener
ejercicios y y estar en actividad dentro
del gobierno porque consideran también
de nuevo que esta reforma podría estar
socavándola legitimidad democrática del
país e incluso algunos miembros del
partido al cual pertenecen etaneado es
el partido licut han también han
solicitado que se detenga esta reforma y
que se planteen nuevas vías para poder
llegar algún tipo de acuerdo para evitar
que la polarización se haga todavía más
profunda creo que para una perspectiva
ya un poco más personal el tema
principal de todo esta cuestión con
nettaneado y en Israel Es que la la
figura de netanía un sí ha generado una
polarización Desde hace no unas cuantas
semanas sino ya desde hace varios
periodos incluso electorales recordemos
que Israel pasó por cinco elecciones
antes de que regresara nettaneado el
poder el gobierno anterior incluso
gobernado por la dupla entre Benny gangs
Perdón entre naftalí bennett y
yahirlapit tardó solamente poco más de
un año y fue una coalición demasiado
multicolor verdad incluso existió un
partido islamista que estuvo dentro de
la dentro de la cartera de gobierno y
esto ha llevado digamos a a esa
inestabilidad casi todo se ha convertido
en los procesos electorales
como que si fuera una un referéndum
sobre si sigue o no netaniado dentro del
poder pues mire Gracias Bryan Acuña
licenciado en relaciones internacionales
por sus apreciaciones casi parecen
elegidas de un libro muy amable y a
nuestros televidentes en directo América
continúen con nosotros ya volvemos con
más
[Música]